hey guys how's it going so a lot of you
may have heard that Apple came out with
an iphone battery charger similar to the
Murphy's and I thought wow that's
interesting so here's what actually
happened and how this all sort of went
down Lamarr Wilson deemed me and told me
it was like I was like 3 a.m. or
something he sent me a message I was
like oh my gosh check this out I'm so
excited that they don't have iPhone
chargers and I don't think either one of
us read that it wasn't for the pluses
and I was half asleep I was like yep got
it ordered it and then he text me and
said oh guess what it's only for the 6s
or 6 that just goes to show you that yes
I may happen to be an Apple sheep I
didn't even read it I can't believe it
but here's what I'm gonna do
Jenna my dear sister sweet sweet sister
of mine Merry Christmas
I am currently unboxing your Christmas
presents I hope that you really like
what I got you Jenna this is something
that I think that you will enjoy here we
have the iPhone 6s smart battery case I
thought I might go ahead and unbox it
for you because you know you've got a
lot going on
I just thought just saying hey a sweet
sister that books your sister's
Christmas present here we go first thing
you'll notice is the massive Apple logo
in the back of it
I put the old silicon case on my iPhone
that I had from before and I loved how
they had this sort of slight indentation
of the Apple logo it's just I feel like
it should be a little bit lighter gray I
don't know why it drives me just so nuts
there's a slight little raise to it so I
am gonna now take this to my sister and
see what she thinks of it it's nice
though it has a good weight it's not
very heavy my current iPhone 6s plus is
very heavy because I have a glass
privacy screen on it so it makes it
almost double the weight that it should
be it's just crazy that it's taken Apple
this long to come out with something
like this and it's also kind of weird
that instead of increasing the battery
life of your phone they just said hey
we know you're having a struggle here's
the answer to your problem so why do
they do this sooner I'm not sure let's
see what Jenna thinks over Christmas
present John I have a present for you
it's a present
no it's nothing that you can eat but
here's the problem is it an apple case
that you got for yourself so you got the
wrong size no it's a Christmas present
for you it's nothing birthday I mean
Merry Christmas
it's just is it actually for me well
you're the wrong size you don't have it
for the six-plus ha ha ha oh look at my
new gift you know I'm actually very so
wait.you jealous so amazing I got all
the cool stuff that you accidentally
ordered
it's a Christmas present okay well it's
a good president whoa what's wrong
let me see what about what am I looking
at Oh did it light up or something no I
told me how much was left with the
battery and how much was left no way
yeah look okay ready gets a shot oh no
way that's wild wild wow that's cool you
to the up to a newly updated no I'm
about to do the update well there you
have it everybody thanks for the case
just I'll get that one of your size when
it's out it's just great cuz the other
day I was like I need to get a new case
why'd you don't have one it's okay is it
for just the 6s yep what about like the
other ones so they're at the 5s I need
six No I'm a Christmas they don't say I
never got your Christmas present I don't
never yeah Jill hey um Jill
is a live stream oh okay